alors michèle torr l'amour a toujours
tenu une grande place dans votre vie
dans vos chansons vous êtes la cliente
idéale pour une interview par amour
[Applaudissements]
oui est-ce que parmi vous seriez prête à
tout arrêter de chanter
par amour du public
on est déjà lui même pas s'ils me disent
ah ben si on me demande ça je ne le
demandait ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à prendre 17 kilos mais je crois
que c
est ce que par amour il est prête à vous
mettre à la drogue du pétard ça fait pas
trop mal
est ce que tu as à rebours soyez pas tu
as changé de chemisiers
est ce que est ce que par amour question
peut-il de coureurs vous seriez prête à
embrasser cent fois ses chaussettes
sales
[Musique]
par amour
oui un peu con
la
drogue le tabac est ce que par amour ou
seriez prête à accepter quelques petites
infidélités
par amour ouais ben tiens évidemment je
suis assez drôle pour qui c'est qui dit
ça c'est vous les hommes qui disent oui
c'est le rendre bah oui sûrement
ça peut arriver ouais vous accepterez
j'aurais du mal à accepter mais c'est
arrivé ça peut arriver voilà c'est
arrivé
est-ce que par amour vous accepteriez
c'est plus grave qu'il ait une maîtresse
non non non non non non non même si ça
le rend heureux
comme ça tu en entends une erreur oui
donc je vous demande pas si par amour ou
seriez prête à vivre à trois avec la
maîtresse non bien sûr j'aurais beaucoup
de mal d'accord il y aurait des morts
aller tous les trois dans un club
échangiste
harris et michel ettorre
prédit emmène moi danser ce soir ce qui
rajoute dans un club échangiste
il suffit d'écouter les disques c'est
pas compliqué
est-ce que par amour je serai prête à
devenir sa super esclaves sexuelles
[Applaudissements]
oui oui comme ça que répondre à
quelques-unes n'ont jamais vu à part
isabelle alonso
est ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
changer de sexe
si vous voulez mais
il vous aime et vous dit si tu m'as tu
m'aimes voilà je t'aime et si tu m'aimes
vraiment devient un homme pour moi dans
une autre vie alors
il pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu